das hier sind gesunde Chips es ist ein
echter Sound nicht dass ihr wieder sagt
das Fake diesen Jack knusprig und die
bestehen aus Wirsing Klick mir ein Blatt
hin Zack und schneide einfach entlang
des Strangs einmal von oben nach unten
weil der Strang wird nicht knusprig der
muss leider weg das ist alles was wir im
Vorbereitung machen müssen ich mache das
eben mit den anderen Blättern jetzt
gehen wir darauf ordentlich Olivenöl man
kann das ein Pinseln ich habe hier so
ein Spray der sogar ein bisschen Chiliöl
drin damit sprühe ich einmal komplett
auf unseren Kohl jetzt wird das ganze
mit geräucherter Paprika Cayennepfeffer
Knoblauchpulver und Salz je mehr Gewürze
desto mehr Geschmack und das gleiche
machen wir von der anderen Seite auch
noch mal schaut das alles gleichmäßig
bedeckt ist ab in den Ofen bis
gleichmäßigem Abstand für 5 Minuten 5
Minuten später fertig sind unsere
kultsche